come on viewers Choice review number two
let me know if you guys are enjoying
this I'm going to keep doing it because
there's always this drought in the
middle of the week in between weekends
where I'm like I need to make a video
right now so you guys vote between
Independence Day and predator and
predator was the clear winner so here we
go with predator
nothing like it has ever been on earth
before we cannot see it but it sees the
heat of our bodies and the heat of our
fear Terminator is fantastic Terminator
2 is great but to be honest predator is
my favorite Arnold Schwarzenegger movie
it's because of so much sustained
attention from beginning to end of that
movie so much testosterone is in this
film I mean you can't like ask for more
testosterone it's directed by John
McTiernan who the very next year then
directed die hard so the guy understands
manliness and I'm a man I am so it
relates to me I feel like yes if I was
in that situation I had all those
weapons if I was one of the last man you
know in that forest I'd be like dude
it's gonna be me and you predator and
put mud all over my body I'm gonna make
traps out of wood and stuff it kills
with pleasure
it hunts for sport
but this time it's picked the wrong man
to hunt all in a group of men are in the
force they're on this mission to try to
rescue these these hostages and they
encounter this otherworldly creature
that's just there and it starts to pick
all them off basically and it's a
fantastic action will be very
suspenseful can I get some love for Alan
Silvestri's score one of my favorite
scores actually tired film with
predators keeps you on the edge of your
seat the tension that John McTiernan is
able to create with that environment
because they're there in a real jungle
they're not on studio sets or anything
McTiernan did a lot of shots were like
the trees obscure the view a little bit
and it just makes you feel like you are
there in that force you're beginning to
feel like sticky like and you're like is
that a bug or what like it just you feel
like you're there it's really cool arm
is actually very good Miss Mary
that's a weird saying that because no
one really thinks of Arnold it's like
this great actor me his first few
characters were pretty much all the same
we shall fear the lamentation of that
women nothing clean right out of beat
back so this is like the first role
where he actually had to be like a
little bit different predators honestly
one of my all-time favorite movies what
more can I say I love predator predator
is a four out of four star movie for
sure it's on my favorites he is the
Ultimate Warrior
if he is to destroy it he must become
more than a man more than an animal he
must become the very spirit of the
predator Arnold Schwarzenegger in
predator soon the hunt will begin so let
me know if you're enjoying this viewers
Choice thing I'm going to leave two more
comments again at the end of this review
and you can thumbs up which one you want
you can choose between Dirty Harry or
gran torino
I want to do a Clint Eastwood movie
predator awesome movie